welcome to the across the Spoilers
Podcast I'm your host Paul as always
Paul the wall joined by none other than
Greg Alba from real rejects Greg how's
it going great to see you again it's
great to see you Paul I'm happy to be
here buddy we got so much on the agenda
today that we gotta swing into action
Paul texted me an entire list of
everything he wants to talk about today
check it everyone writer strike VFX
artist unionizing Stephen Mel DC with
arrow The Rock and Black Adam when he
was on Kevin Hart Blue Beetle reactions
he said some DCU stuff not sure what
he's referring to Wonder Woman three he
saw Heart of Stone gal starring in Snow
White might talk about Rachel zegler
we'll see how we feel and the Marvel's
director uh said some stuff but before
we go into any of that Paul last time we
were here it was your birthday when we
were filming how was your birthday buddy
yeah it was really good I actually had a
week off work it was really nice um Mt
as I'm sure you've seen you guys you're
loyal if you're watching this podcast
you loyal to the channel Mt is now
hosting with us full-time he handled a
lot of stuff last week so I just gotta
actually take some time out and and
relax I've also just been at The Fringe
in Edinburgh which is quite a big thing
and talking about social media and stuff
and yeah it's been just a nice relaxing
week to get away get away from all you
suckers you damn chubs what about you
Greg
my week was good I was just thinking
about you the whole time and I hope
Paul's enjoying his time off what people
don't know is Paul is actually still
working you know he had a week off but
there was there was a couple of things
that happened he had to get that upgrade
can I reveal a little bit about this
man's work yeah yeah go for it he had to
do like a re-edit constant like 20
something uploads or whatever
and he's messaging me this I thought you
had the week off man I had the week he's
still working his butt off man that's
the kind of man Paul is he cares about
you guys that much despite his British
sarcasm but yeah we should uh we should
get into all the all the good stuff what
do you want to go with first man
so yeah let's talk about the VFX artists
unionizing um so apparently there's 50
who all work heavily with Marvel that
I've just said we're sick of this thing
we're absolutely sick of the way we're
being treated now if you've been paying
attention to a lot of controversial
Stories the last year there's been a ton
of things about VFX artists and how
Marvel will just come in last minute and
after they've worked on stuff for months
and be like actually can we change this
entire character and it's not just a
case of like switching a couple of
things here and there you have to
reanimate a whole scene and yeah it's
just leading I I think one of the big
criticisms with marvel at the moment is
probably it's CGI you know beyond the
storytelling and these VFX artists have
been coming out and saying look this is
why it's this way and it's a lot of very
tight deadlines obviously Marvel have a
lot of projects at the moment and
they're just trying to basically do what
I think everyone should be entitled to
which is unionize get job security and
better benefit fits
yeah I mean I think this is long overdue
action they absolutely deserve it
because to provide a tiny bit of clarity
here this is for the VFX artists who are
actively on set I think sometimes when
people are hearing this they're thinking
it's like when you go to the credits on
a Marvel movie and you see the thousands
of digital effects artists they're
they're important too and ultimately
when you think about it for drastic
change to happen you need to hopefully a
lot of them are independent contractors
too A lot of them are freelance so down
the road it would be great for all them
unionized in some capacity but to
protect these guys is very very vital
and I I think too there's a lot of Merit
to be had when you have people on a
proper schedule and proper protection
and whatnot because it forces everyone
to sort of be creative you know for
yourself Paul like with having employees
and then having uh time frames and being
aware of overtime pay which is something
that a lot of of them are wanting to be
looked out for and also to be having
their you know proper lunch breaks as
well these like basic human needs when
you're working anywhere to be protected
that's something that forces someone
like in my position with other people
your position with other people to
really make sure that they are being
well taken care of and forces you and
everyone else to work they call it a
union but this allows us to work within
Unity that much better so I feel like
this is great for the for the long term
and it's a lot it's going to be a hard
battle it's gonna be an uphill battle
but it's one worth fighting absolutely I
think it's showing the state of the
world at the moment
um I've been you know you see capitalism
now I'm probably I'm not a Marxist or
anything but um you start like looking
at some of the stuff the guy said and it
starts to make a bit of sense so I
called Marx famously theorized that the
end of capitalism would come when the
the gap between the billionaires and the
workers were so vast
um and inequality was so high that
eventually the whole system would
collapse and you know we're not really I
don't think I think that's a while off
guys no no Doom and Gloom but um you're
starting to see a lot of things
especially in Hollywood where people are
just going on strike and thinking I'm
not going to work anymore what was the
famous quote he said when all when the
workers have nothing left to lose but
they're chains they will rise up and
something like that and I think you are
starting to see that point where the the
gap between you know the the Haves and
have-nots has gone so vast in the
workforce that people are just like I'm
you know what I'm not doing it mate I'm
not doing it anymore you can either pay
us more give us a bit more money we're
in a cost of living crisis or we're just
not going to work and you're not gonna
make any money either
um so yeah we're heading to this
socialist Utopia okay everyone's turning
off already no let's go with the
Socialist Utopia Put Me In Charge guys
no I don't think it will get to that I
think eventually you know the the
billionaires and rich people might
realize like oh crap we are kind of
screwed up here if we keep screwing
people over so they'll hopefully
you know spread stuff out agree to these
strike terms or at least try and
negotiate stuff where it's fairer now
moving on to the next topic before
everyone who's left who's like the
bloody marxists they're bloody I knew it
they were Communists the whole time I'll
try to transition just as quickly as
possible I gotta move on before I lose
everyone
but uh yeah so we're moving on to the
the strikes next
um yeah what's been the update because
there has been a couple of things here
and there that they've talked about uh
yeah I mean there's a quote here uh that
they've The Guild released a writer
strike of the writers released uh I'll
speed read it really quick for you guys
but try to be as eloquent as possible
you're negotiating Community oh my God I
already messed it up Paul already messed
it up your negotiating committee
received a counter proposal from the
amptp today we will evaluate their offer
and after deliberation go back to them
with the wga's response next week so
what they went on to say was sometimes
more progress can be made in
negotiations with air conductor without
a Blow by blow description on the moves
of each side and a subsequent public
that section of the meaning of the moves
that will be our Approach at least for
the time being until there's something
of significance to report or unless
management uses the media or industry
surrogates to try to influence the
narrative
um so I mean they said a little bit more
stuff after that but the bottom line is
that they have a proposal from amptp and
a lot of the rhetoric surrounding the
writer strike obviously has been we got
nothing there's nothing that's being
told our way and they don't want to go
to the negotiating table with us sounds
like they've finally got some offer and
rather than trying to put things out in
the public and get a discourse going
about that since a lot of this seems to
be you know a bit of a public it's
obviously a public battle and a lot of
that seems to factor in to the
negotiations that they have something to
consider now they have something to
actually go over and maybe there is
something here that can influence the
direction of where the writers can
finally get back to actually writing and
working with the studios but who knows
this is the most of it's like an update
that they have an update we just don't
know what the specifics of the update
actually are
yeah I mean I'm hoping that this gets
resolved really quickly and then the the
actor strike follows suit pretty quickly
after
um I would love for it to all be done
very quickly so David zazlab was hopeful
that everyone would be back to work by
September but you know 15 days time
we'll have to see
um
ah I'm kind of all over the place with
everything at the moment in terms of
just what's going on with streaming in
general because it does like when you
hear the Disney plus reports and stuff
it does seem to be actually costing
these companies quite a lot I'm sure
Disney revealed that they lost 11
billion on streaming alone and it's
absolutely crazy I think what the
problem was and this is across YouTube
as well because Greg we've been we've
been like doing this as well I know that
a lot of other YouTubers have done it
too where we've looked at views in the
pandemic and we've been like
once we've come out of it we've been
like oh crap views are down views are
down they're not what they used to be
when I was and I started thinking about
it no views were up in the pandemic
because everyone was in the house
watching YouTube Netflix and so on so
the pandemic sort of inflated everything
and made that become The New Normal
whereas if covid hadn't have happened
views would have been a lot lower
because people have been in the
workplace and they wouldn't be working
from home or just watching YouTube all
the time and and so on so I think the
companies just they they saw that
massive boom where everything was just
Tiger King was the biggest show in the
world squid game biggest show of all
time and they thought oh we're gonna
we're gonna make loads of money here and
invest so much into it and they haven't
done it and you know it's it's starting
to show and I think everyone just needs
to take a step back and go no views on
down views are normal it was the
pandemic where views were up so just uh
they just need to think about that and
realize and and stop going crazy with
everything and maybe put the money into
into the people in in the projects and
stop just going crazy all the time now
in regards to the strikes there's been
another update from a guy who got a bit
shamed last week Stephen Amell and he
obviously had a lot of yeah he had a lot
of controversy with the strikes and he
actually showed up at the SAG after a
picket line looking happy as always
yeah I said it was like when when your
mom says that you have to go to your
Auntie's birthday party and you just
like I'll show my face for 15 minutes
and then I'm out he kind of looks it
kind of looks a bit you know upset to be
there but you know to be fair I mean
what else can the guy do at least at
least he went back and did it you know
what I mean there are people saying that
it's a PR opportunity how do you feel
about it
it's I mean it's obviously a PR
opportunity the guy's been extremely
clear on where he stands on all these
things ultimately it's a it's a no-win
situation the second they took that
photo with him he had to have known he's
going to be met with a lot of hate
because you got two camps here right you
got the one Camp which doesn't seem like
the majority who is not really for the
strike and is like they're trying to
control your opinion Stephen Amell
so you have that side who thinks I then
he got pushed he got the woke him up
pushed him into uh going against his own
morals and beliefs sure maybe and then
you got the other side who has been very
much against Stephen Amell for what he
said and then he's showing up and you're
like oh he's just doing this because of
publicity you know there's no chance
this guy's gonna win ultimately he made
the right decision I think bottom line
he just had to be at the picket line
regardless everything every decision
that has to be made right now we got to
be thinking about the long term with
everything like you were just talking
about
um like when it comes to views and stuff
with with how we were all reacting to it
and then you see how reactionary the
studios became to it and right now the
studios themselves they have to be
factoring in the long-term effects of
zazlov's little call about like hey we
actually saved a lot of money recently
it's silly because long term this is
going to really affect everything and
that could lead to more of a financial
dip so you apply that kind of mentality
to Stephen Amell he knows he's got a
show he's in support it's all about the
Optics right now he's got a show look at
the end of the day I am here to support
everyone even if he doesn't look happy
to be there he looks like the same
brooding Oliver Queen that we all know
him to be so yeah honestly on a down a
little bit of a Down I I really I used
to really love uh looking this guy up on
videos have you seen this American Ninja
Warrior video where he I think it was
America so cool so cool saw my Comic-Con
once he just seemed like such an awesome
person and uh it's sad but we'll all
move on he's a he's a handsome talented
white boy we like him we'll like him
eventually again
I bet he did flirt with the idea of
rocking up to the the picket line
wearing a heels t-shirt to promote his
new show but you know what Greg I was
thinking about this through the week and
there's been times where I've worked
with other people who they've done
something wrong they shouldn't have been
doing but they weren't exactly told
before they started like don't do this
thing but they did it and then you know
someone who stepped in had a word with
him and say look mate can you stop doing
this now your option is to still be
angry at them for doing it in the first
place or if they stop doing it and
change just be like
well they did do what I they stopped
doing it I'm just gonna have to let it
go and that's kind of how I look at it
with with Stephen Amell you know he made
a comment
people told them look mate stop stop
you're wrong you shouldn't be against
the strike especially you who are an
actor and he's thought okay and and came
in went on the picket line
and no I don't agree with the last
statement that he made before all this
just gonna have to let it go and say
well at least he's doing it now so I I
think he you know the two options were
either go or don't go and I think the
the worst option out of those two was to
not go and not show his face and so at
least he's doing this thing where he's
like no I am showing solidarity with the
strikes
so yeah kind of
I get you can argue that it's a PR move
but we don't know that for definite I
mean I'm sure it's always going to stick
with them but we I we can suspect it but
we can't say for definite yeah yeah I
mean yeah there's they're like lasting
on it there was some slight controversy
about oh the Arrow cast was there uh but
he wasn't with them and it was he was in
a different state I think he was in New
York if I'm not mistaken he was in New
York watching a friend's Broadway show
so that's why he was at that picket line
versus the LA line and Mark Guggenheim
the executive producer of Arrow has said
he had a good conversation with the guy
so it's all good what do you want to
talk about next man that was good I
think we're doing good we are speeding
through this efficient quality today I
like it okay
so yeah the rock talked about Black Adam
recently with um Kevin Hart what did you
think about that what was it what would
he even say I watched it but I can't
really I just think he said stuff he'd
said before really in regards to Black
Adam and I think that Black Adam
got caught in Vortex new leadership it
was so many changes in leadership anyway
you have a company a public eye that
one's boring uh is this about
philosophically changes and I think
Black Adam is one of those movies it's a
lot about Black Adam getting caught in
web of new leadership and that you know
him and Kevin Hart Think about audience
first the part of it that really stood
out to me I'm just gonna go into the
part that stood out to me was yes he's
saying that a lot of this got caught up
in the changes that DC was going through
and then a new leader wants to have
different directions and he kept him and
Kevin Hart kept uh harping on the fact
that Black Adam had such a successful
opening weekend and that you know people
were excited about like the diversity
and Henry Cavill returning
there was so much emphasis though on the
opening weekend but not the film's
actual box office run worldwide
and it seems like he's not acknowledging
that ultimately the film did
underperform ultimately it did not
actually gain them a lot financially and
that probably has a big factor as well
as to why they did not want to continue
yes James Gunn has his vision for what
he wants to do next and the way they're
trying to it's like Dwayne Johnson seems
like a guy who generally knows how to
take a loss but he doesn't seem to
acknowledge this side of it granted
though it was one of those films like
Mission Impossible if I'm not mistaken I
could be wrong here feel free to correct
me and yell at me in the comments that
Black Adam was one of those movies that
did have the coveted problems that
probably inflated its budget a lot more
as well so maybe it could have easily
profited if it didn't have to deal with
that hurdle
But ultimately the film was not a box
office success and the way he talks
about it here
the way he talks about it here the
tenure of his voice is pretty much the
film did great don't know why we didn't
get a sequel when that is not indeed the
reality of the situation but what do you
think man
the the quote we said a few times is
something like not my coach not my
quarterback or something and talking
about how and yeah yeah and he said that
a couple of times in different
interviews and from what I heard what
was going on behind the scenes was that
both the Rock and James Gunn had Visions
for the way the DCU should go and zazlab
was kind of like weighing up what to do
and we we've kind of heard about this
power struggle behind the scenes
and the the bat basically black Adam's
box office was what caused things to
swing in favor of James Gunn and that
kind of got him kicked out now he has
said that you know Black Adam won't be
in this phase of the DCU right but I'm
kind of wondering what the hell is going
on with the whole thing because
I I kind of feel like James Gunn is sort
of not promising stuff but he's saying
like well you know we could try and work
together in the future on something and
this is yeah this is something that's
also been seen in Gal Gadot who it was a
crazy back and forth throughout the week
where you had one minute you know she's
obviously been promoting Heart of Stone
or she was before the strike and so so
some of the comments are kind of a bit
old for example she talked about the
Superman casting before it had actually
happened but the way the interviews
released it was coming out after we
already knew who was playing the part
and she said that she had met and with
James gonna be a saffron and they'd kind
of work together to to talk about how
they would develop Wonder Woman 3 going
forward because Patty Jenkins famously
got told basically to get the hell out
of the the thing with her script or
she's some something happened some other
not um altercation but there was some
drama yeah where Patty Jenkins was
basically told like we don't want your
Wonder Woman three so going forward
um Gal Gadot has apparently been told
that she's gonna be an integral part of
the DCU and that they'll develop Wonder
Woman 3 together now the next day
it came out I think was from variety or
one of those Hollywood trades saying it
was deadline okay good we won't get sued
um so deadline said that that was all
wrong actually and you know Gaga wasn't
going to be in Wonder Woman three and
then there's been back and forth and no
one kind of knows what's going on now
I've said from the start hard reboot it
I think if you've got you know a
different Batman in Superman then you
you really do need to just think about
you know let's wipe this like clean and
start with it it's getting to that point
now where I I kind of feel
from what we know it doesn't even feel
like it's a real reboot
um The Flash gave the perfect
opportunity to just wipe the board clean
start again but obviously we've got
Aquaman 2 still coming out Blue Beetle
though it's marketed as being you know
the first hero of the DCU you you've
seen it so but we'll talk about this
later on um but I haven't so there it
has been reported that there's Man of
Steel references in it which I don't
know how that would make sense if Man of
Steel has now been retconned by The
Flash and I I don't feel like they even
needed to announce this reboot I think
James Gunn coming out and saying you
know we're doing a whole new DCU before
before these films had released I do
feel like it damaged the box office not
to a massive amount but I do feel like
you know something's happened and it it
has made these films stiff
um and I just don't get why they did it
because kavlin Affleck they were already
thought to be out anyway so we like the
last couple of years it those two it's
always been like well they might come
back and do things but you know the The
Stance is at the moment that they're out
and that's why Henry Cavill coming back
for Black Adam was such a big thing at
the time because it was like oh crap
they've got him back
um so that there was you know there
would have had to be something in place
at some point to recast both Batman and
Superman anyway and I feel that they
might as well have just kept things
moving you know announced James Gunn was
in charge but not really done it in a
way that would kill the interest of
these last DC EU films
um and I just feel like you know Warner
Brothers the thing that people have
constantly criticized for the last 10
years is the lack of management
throughout the whole DCU uh DC EU sorry
where there's been just so much
mismanagement and no clear Direction and
that's kind of what it feels like you
know you've traded in all that crap but
more crap where it's happening like one
day we're getting reports that gal
gadot's back as Wonder Woman three and
then the next day it's like oh no she's
not she's not never coming back and and
it just feels like the mismanagement's
continuing and making it really
difficult to have faith in this universe
I'll be honest with you if James Gunn
hadn't made so many bangers I would have
zero faith in this universe you know the
guy's done enough that I think you can
give him the benefit of the doubt
but it doesn't feel like this fresh
exciting reboot that's Gonna Save DC
Studios you know what I mean there's
it's it's very much just seems like more
of the same stuff from before with a
different Batman Superman and Lois Lane
yeah well it feels more like they're
transitioning than it does for you yeah
fresh start you know and maybe a
transition isn't as exciting as a full
reboot
I think he's trying to be respectful in
in some regards you know James Gunn
there was a time where he was constantly
shooting down every single thing that
was incorrect I feel like maybe it's
different because it's Gal Gadot and he
wants to he's got a little bit more
respectful or something like that
because it's her
I feel like that should have been
something he clarified because she says
something and then all the trades are
like is this true is this true they're
all looking it up and then no our
sources are saying this is not true and
it's something that I think it would
have behooved him to clarify a little
bit as opposed to
lending more into this this strange
strange narrative but you know speaking
of uh Wonder of James Gunn his partner
Peter saffron who is the producer I
believe of Blue Beetle Blue Beetle has
had some early reactions my friend some
of these people too were also at the
screening that I went to and it's really
positive reception have you read through
them
yeah it has but I've got to the point
now where I don't really trust early
reactions because as you they're always
the same they're always like it's the
best movie since the Dark Knight yeah
yeah I don't think that at all I read
that I read someone who did this someone
that did say that actually no that is
one of the quotes is that someone said
festival and since the Dark Knight or
something like that film and it is it's
not I don't I wouldn't I would not go
that far
however you know
I will say uh all the reactions are
about what you'd expect you know good
tight-knit family film a great great
representation of Latino culture and I
messaged you after I saw it and I said
that the movie is actually really fun
you know it hasn't the long story short
I got a review coming up this week go a
lot more into detail about it
long story short if at least from my end
of the experience and I'm kind of going
off of how I was feeling even even with
the crowd is that the First Act of this
movie it's a bit of a rocky start and
honestly I wasn't I didn't think I was
gonna like the movie I thought like oh
this is really bad this feels made for
TV
but once it gets into the actual plot of
the film you know the whole thing with
scare up and Blue Beetle everything
really starts to click and I would
actually Echo
I wouldn't Echo that it's the best film
since the Dark Knight it's a it's a
solid film it's I really enjoyed it it's
not there's like it does not like it
gets great and then it just stays that
way the bad still interweaves throughout
the the rest of the film however I would
still say that yeah I'm actually in
alignment with vast majority of the
early reactions and it was pretty
similar to what I actually messaged you
after I watched the movie actually this
was a pleasant surprise it was genuinely
a fun movie and and I know that's kind
of a cop-out for comic book movies it is
it's fun
this one actually is this one actually
was a good time and you could feel the
crowd getting one over two like no
laughs or anything but then by the end
it does earn some gen like some genuine
Applause and uh I even got a little
emotional on myself at certain moments I
gotta say I gotta say man but is your
interest in it at all
I feel like judging off the the trailer
that it's very cliche and it's kind of
something we've seen done a lot of times
before in the 2000s just some of the
lines when it was like you care about
your family that makes you weak like oh
it's the old do your family makes you
weak thing
um but I mean but it's well done it just
yeah it just feels like another comic
book movie rather than something special
everyone should go see and unfortunately
I I don't feel like it's it's being
pushed to the level that it should be I
I went to book some tickets my local
Cinema no showings at all on Friday the
one that's about five mile away the
Odeon it's got four showings for the
whole day
that and now compare that to something
like Mission Impossible Oppenheimer
Barbie they were like every hour and
they were across IMAX
um super screen at my local cineworld
uh 3D some of them were you know
and there was a big push for it whereas
with this it's like four showings a day
2D standard screen it doesn't feel like
them they're pushing it as an event at
least in the UK and I put a tweet out
about this today and a lot of people
from England kind of echoed my thoughts
and yeah it doesn't feel like that the
studio not being confident kind of
strips me of my confidence in it almost
because I us but then but then again to
be fair they they might have used all
that Goodwill up on the flash you know
what I mean they they really marketed
that that was like next level marketing
saying this like one of the best comic
book movies of all time and you can't
it's very difficult to do that twice
but I feel it should be getting more
than four showings a day if they want
people to be excited and they they have
confidence in it that it's gonna be a
good movie that's well received yeah at
the moment it's tracking for 30 million
opening weekend hell yeah which is very
low and yeah just starting off your your
DCU with this guy being the first hero
you know will I get rolled back and you
know is that gonna get
we'll have to see we'll have to see well
what I will say that I think really does
okay yeah it it is I even said it in my
review it's not exactly the most
original thing it's it feels like a
Marvel phase one movie in a lot of ways
the good and the bad
however the thing that I thought really
distinguishes itself from all those
other ones because a lot of it does feel
derivative of other films the thing that
really distinguishes itself is The
Ensemble a lot of the times in these
comic book movies where you have you
think of any I don't know like Scott
Lang's family or whatever even this or
even the shazamoli uh the Shazam family
and and part one
they're like there but they're not
really you know it doesn't really still
feel like an ensemble movie they don't
feel as integral to the plot from
beginning to end
what really shined in this movie was a
massive takeaway was was The Ensemble
from beginning to end
excluding one of the family members most
of them vast majority of them they
really really shine and are such a heart
of the film
and there's a lot of this emphasis on
like Latino culture and these early
reactions and I thought it was
interweaved in a way that did not feel
forced it they never like turned to the
camera to be like aren't Mexicans cool
or something like it's just like there
the entire time because the personality
feels authentic to the to the experience
and so I I think that is the thing that
really separates it from a lot of the
things that otherwise feel like
underwhelming villains are definitely
there
um the a lot of the it goes pretty much
the direction you'd expect it to go and
I did not know the post-credit leak
and and then sure enough
I won't say anything
yeah yeah it was uh it was a predict
predictable film
but I will say yes it acts for the most
part I liked it more than the flash uh I
I was a pretty easy answer for me that I
was like this is I like this more than
the Flash and I could see it having good
legs based off of just good word of
mouth and I could see him and the way
the movie plays it he could be the end
of the DC EU or he could be the start of
the DC it could you could go either
Direction They I think they were really
smart with how they edited the film to
make sure it can go either way because
even uh Show Low he said that it all
depends on the box office for this film
yeah which is a shame because again it
doesn't really look like they're pushing
it and you know you need a lot of
screenings to make the money
unfortunately
um so showing it four times a day you
know what's the what's the maximum
amount tickets you can sell from that
so yeah um but he's
Show Low is he's not the only person
from the DC Universe with the film out
this week and there was of course Heart
of Stone with Gal Gadot so yeah I
watched this on Friday
um it's getting absolutely slated online
I don't think it's as terrible as
everyone's saying but it's it's a
Netflix action movie basically
um and watching it I was thinking this
is like an old James Bond script that
they had lying around where they thought
you know we'll change some of the
character names and it'll become a new
thing and there are very very
predictable things in it for example
one of the agents who's her friend gets
on a ski lift to
take a hostage in and when they get to
the bottom of the the ski lift they they
have a fight and the the hostage comes
off and oh he's bitten down on the
cyanide capsule and it's kind of like oh
well he's either done that himself or
the other agents double cross them in
these a double agent and stuff like that
you know what I mean if you can figure
it out straight away and there's a scene
where she hangs from a helicopter with
um two the the villain and his helper
who both have parachutes but she doesn't
have a parachute it's kind of like well
what's she gonna do here and obviously
you know you know she's gonna
Cut the Rope and then grab grab the
person so that she she can steal that
parachute it's just all stuff like that
that you can call straight away as soon
as you see the scene
um
finding it you know everyone kind of
rips it for acting but I think if she if
she had a different accent I think it's
very much a an army situation where
people get so focused on the accent that
they just
it almost takes them out of the
performance and you know she's just got
an accent to me it's not outstanding
oscar-winning acting but it's not the
worst thing that I've ever seen a lot of
the memes on her are like Khalil no
give me the stone and stuff like that
which you know if you're saying it in a
cockney British accent I'm sure it
should be fine I'm sure I should be
loved but yeah I think gal gadot's one
of those she's like she's like an Arnie
she's like a Keanu Reeves you kind of
have to write
for
her
capability of talent in terms of line
delivery and and such I think that is
like she can be like she's I think she's
amazing in that first Wonder Woman movie
and I think she's great in um in Batman
v Superman and she's even good in the in
the Fast and Furious movies like she's
if you write just like you gotta write
just write for her or other if you ask
too much it can be distracting I would
say the same thing for Keanu Reeves and
Arnold Schwarzenegger like you don't
want to push too much you gotta write
just right for them you know yeah like
Keanu Reeves amazing is John Wick
perfect is Neo but if you put him in
like Bram Stoker's Dracula Aquarius cup
you know play a British guy can't quite
do it can't quite do it and uh if it's
delivery in John Wick four and in some
of the later Matrix movies was was not
the greatest denial and gentleman for
one of my favorite movies of the year
and uh even there yeah it's not the
greatest get me a gun I need it that's
it yeah but you're not going to those
movies for for the acting you know what
I mean yeah if Carl could not showed up
in like uh an oscar-winning period piece
um discussing the the inner workings of
Victorian marriage I I could say more of
the complaints but you know it's an
action set piece film with very cliched
Over the Top Spice stuff a great car
chasing actually yeah is the action good
though is the action worth it yeah some
of it is yeah some of it's quite good
and they have some
they have some creative stuff on like a
on a a a zeppelin I want to say the the
skydiving seems good the car chase is
good
um it starts up really well with a
parachute scene where she's got a
parachute down a mountain those bits
work fine I do kind of feel like Netflix
is almost cheapening Itself by doing
these bug standard action releases
um because it's going to get to the
point where it's very much like the
Disney plus MCU shows where you're gonna
see an audience drop off because they've
been so mid that people are just now
expecting it to be mid yeah and they you
know if they keep doing these sort of
middle level action movies people are
just not going to watch them I feel
extraction is the only exception to it
like the true exception is extraction
and and these movies damage that because
like let's be honest if extraction two
if there'd be anything else out that
week we probably would have been like
I'm not bothering it like um they cloned
Tyrone that was another perfect example
I know it's not a full and action movie
but it released the same time as Barbie
and Oppenheimer and I was just like oh
well those two other movies are probably
better
um and it's an Ethics movie so uh they
mustn't have much Faith that's gonna be
good absolutely excellent film
um
and yeah I feel heavy yeah
crazy okay that'd be a good reaction for
the channel
um so yeah I feel
that having these mid-level movies does
kind of pull down your stuff like
extraction to where that that should
have been you know a big thing
um and it is a shame to see but yeah
just to kind of garlic action movie I'm
sure they'll probably do another one
um
and yeah just keep pumping it out now
Gal Gadot yeah with a bit of a tenuous
link but she's starring in Snow White
now
Rachel zegler who also stars in Snow
White she's been getting loads of [__]
online loads of it I think she's
becoming like the new Brie Larson in all
honesty I think uh Brie Larson's kind of
a couple of years ago if uh you guys
might remember if you are on the
internet you couldn't you couldn't even
load the home page without running into
a Brie Larson video
um and I think segler's getting it now
but you know a common to a controversial
she's basically saying Prince Charming
was a stalker
the Snow White from the 30s was
problematic
I'm probably gonna alienate a lot of my
audience right now
um if you're under
23 but Rachel zegler is 22 and this is
just how I imagine most 22 year olds to
be these days
where I'd say oh have you seen that
movie from uh have you seen Bambi oh
yeah but it's really problematic isn't
it like and I say all right okay and
then just cough on a Spiel where they
tell you about all the things that you
liked as a kid and how wrong they are
these days and I just kind of feel like
you know she's she's a young person
who's been
thrust into the Limelight to talk about
things and she's just kind of going off
on a yeah a sort of tirade about how
Prince Charming was a stalker and yeah
it's not gonna work out well I think it
all started when she I don't remember
exactly what she said it was something
when she was on this on the picket lines
for sag and then she was saying I you
know for every second it's streaming I
should be getting paid for it and some
yeah something about a dress wasn't it
it was like if I stand in a dress for 18
hours a day I should be paid for it and
then you know people would come in and
be like what about those and I think
there's actually something to be said
about that with the people at Disneyland
who have to really know the characters
in and out and have to stay in character
all day and are just compensated by hour
when they're there
yeah like I I get what she's saying and
I don't ultimately feel what she's even
saying about Snow White is inherently
all that bad honestly I I
I I was like yeah I mean the movie's
dated like like she said it's dated it
was it was like the first big Disney uh
animated movie right if I'm not mistaken
like the first big one I haven't seen it
for years to be honest I can't remember
I didn't find it offensive at the time
let's say that no no I mean God you go
to any movie you could find problems
with it if it's before
2022. we're like you're gonna find
anything that is a problem with
everything
um but the the thing is is that like
there's some weird [__] she's saying
here that just doesn't sound like it's
snow white you know like she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be the leader and her late father
told her that she could be if she was
Fearless Fair Brave and true and uh she
said like I was scared of the original
version I think I watched it once and
never picked it up again and of course
the line about the the stalker and the
prince charming one
I think the way how she's saying it
because ultimately these Disney movies
are in a weird debuggle the the live
action remix right you you want that I
like The Little Mermaid I I actually
really like that one and to me
it could still have a like a no-win side
of an audience member because
yeah it's they're trying to be so much
like the original you're trying to
they're like what's the point if it's
trying to be so much like the original
and then you swing way too far the
opposite direction and then you're
upsetting the people who want it to be
more pure to the original and we're in
this day and age where they want it to
be more empowering have more modern
relevance to it and I could see the pro
of it being like a more a broader role
model like with the the things she's
saying could have a deeper character
depth to it basically so I think that
it's not inherently bad it's just the
way she talks about it
yeah it doesn't sound as bad in tone
when you listen to the clips like she
seems like she's actually having some
fun when she's talking about it I think
the tone that they that people often
apply when they just read the quotes is
the tone that we saw of her on the SAG
strike video where she was very upset
and very passionate during there but
when she talks about the snow white
stuff at least when I watch the actual
Clips it doesn't sound like she's like
raging out about the original Snow White
but it does communicate when you just
read it as if she hates the original
film and then when you're hearing what
this new one's going for it sounds
so different from the original yeah and
it's like well what do we what do we
want as an audience so we want it to be
very different do we want it to be
exactly the same and
is there is there Merit to I I think
something that we try to steer away from
too is the romanticizing aspects of
these Disney movies like I'm talking
about specifically the romance in these
Disney films yeah it is weird and then
I'm like that's such a to me that's an
integral part of the Snow White uh story
is to have her it's like there's nothing
wrong with romance and there's ways to
to flesh it out they didn't read a girl
wig write this movie
she did that's right yeah I don't know I
feel like it might I do I completely
agree I completely agree with the
romance thing that's something I've
noticed recently in a lot of films where
they'll take love interests and just
completely remove them from the film
um and I don't I don't know why they've
started doing it I quite like a good
love story in the middle of my thing
they start doing it in Mission
Impossible where you know Bond famously
would have Bond girls and then Mission
Impossible was like uh we'll get get rid
of the romance and I think they realize
at some point like we'll try and do
stuff with ilsa but then they ultimately
didn't really do much with it
um I I disagree slightly with watching
her saying it on the red carpet and and
talking about it I think
she might have came across a bit smoke
to people
um which which one was a red carpet I
might not have been a red carpet but
just where she was calling Prince
Charming a stalker and stuff he's my
blood he's my really good mate I learned
everything I know from no of course
um going back to those old films you you
might find problems with them I think
just in general like as a rule of thumb
if you're remaking something or you're
starring in something that's beloved you
have to respect the source material or
at least appear like you do and maybe
not come out slagging it off now Henry
Cavill is a great example of that you
might remember there were rumors that he
was very difficult to work with and you
know people
um which I found I found him hard to get
along with yeah and then everyone's kind
of like oh I've heard he's a [__]
but then what it was explained to be was
that no he actually just really likes
the source material and he's trying to
make it as accurate as possible and then
suddenly ever everyone flipped to his
side and was like oh well if he's just
respecting The Source material then let
him be a [__] because he's trying to
get this thing as perfect as possible I
think in general
if if I I think actors should just be
more careful about if something's
Beloved the chat and it's got a big fan
base you coming in and saying actually
that's all wrong your [__] were
liking it it was very problematic we're
doing a new version It's better it's all
news ideologies uh mod well updating it
for modern audiences I think people who
have gained a love and attachment to
that are gonna find it maybe insulting
because they're like well are they
saying that I'm wrong for liking this
thing and you know I feel like Disney
are sort of tying themselves and not
sometimes to try and not not offend
everyone and for example you know the
the Seven Dwarves then they're not seven
dwarves in this film anymore there
considered magical mystical beings and
obviously you know that there is a
debate there that it's offensive to to
little people and obviously Peter
Dinklage spoke out about it but on the
flip side of that there was a lot of
people who said
um well this is taking away our jobs you
know it's we're not being shown in media
anymore
and I think Disney also sort of need to
realize like kids don't really get
offended by stuff like when I was like
when I was a kid none of us got offended
really by anything I think the people
who get offended by stuff tend to be
adults who's probably spend too much
time on Twitter and just feel like they
need to be overreactive and give their
opinion all the time kids on the whole
don't really get offended like you you
I'm sure I could show my children Snow
White right now and they're not gonna be
sitting there going this is very
problematic and it's a stereotypical
depiction of this Pro problematic thing
you know they're not going to get
offended by it and I think Disney
sometimes forget who their target
audience is and they try and cater more
to not offending overreactive adults on
Twitter who will just complain about how
evil and bad everything is when you know
the the intent's not really there and
there's not really the evidence to back
it up
um I saw a guy with the win have you
seen Gone With the Wind what I mean what
would be talking about 30 years ago
maybe in a problem which is the first
time I'm sure that's very problematic as
well yeah I've watched that and I'm like
wow I mean this movie that movie would
swept the Oscars right like it had like
all the Oscars and you just gotta
replace yourself in a
you got places
especially with the cinema you know take
the core elements I think you just take
the core elements
um you know Snow White this is what I
remember of Snow White which is one the
wicked witch wants to kill her because
she's more beautiful than she is she
flees into the forest with the hunter
who's gonna kill her he lets her go
um she stumbled I mean I've watched it
for about 25 years bear in mind but she
stumbles across the Seven Dwarves or
something yeah chills out with their
wicked witch finds out that she's still
alive disguises herself as an old woman
goes and tries to kill her at Prince
Charming or something shows up those are
the plot beats right nothing in that is
really problematic
um or you know it's gonna cause massive
issues online and I think you know you
just take those plot beats there you
kind of just keep it keep it because
that's what people remember and I'm sure
if I went back and watched it I'd be
like oh maybe she had a point
um but yeah keep those just keep those
plot points in and then don't come out
and be like anyone who likes it to an
IST or something like that you know what
I mean just say
and she was she wasn't obviously saying
that accusing people of who like it of
being a nist I'm putting words in them
out there I'll admit that but I feel
like she's just being like yeah I mean
it can come across especially if you
know I know people are not gonna like me
saying this I think it is a reality
though
I think when you're a woman it is so
much harder too like you will get
clowned on so much more and and we all
we all know it whether or not you want
to admit it or not we all know it it is
so much easier to be a Target in these
situations and
even even that thing that sure can come
across like a little bit she can't come
I can see how people can see she comes
across a little smog maybe she is I
don't know her personally none of us do
most of us don't know a person
it's a tone smoke might be the wrong
word but I think it was sort of her
being like I know better than you guys
who like this thing yeah yeah no it I
can I can totally understand if it comes
across that way and I think when you're
a woman
that's gonna hit so many more buttons
than if a guy actually does it it's just
the way it goes and I don't want to be
here and be like woman get yourself in
check here you know because that's
unfair that um I don't think you're
coming across like that at all I think
you're talking more about Society kind
of just jumping on women for for saying
things and giving their opinion which at
the end of the day it's it's her opinion
and she she kind of feels that you know
what I've been ageist already where I'm
coming from is I am I am so tired of
people hating something
before it's there was even a freaking
trailer for the movie you know and it's
it's reached that point with her where
everyone just hates this already so just
give it a chance let's just wait let's
just wait all that controversy with
Halle Bailey and like a Little Mermaid
and stuff and then you see it and you're
like she's great most people and I agree
she's the the best part of the movie
she's amazing in that film and so let's
just wait maybe the
actors say things sure let it annoy you
right now if you want uh but don't
simmer there let's just wait for the
movie and see if it's ultimately a
disaster Fest or
you know I know it's easy to especially
on YouTube we can easily just like
really rail into this and make our
thumbnails with the big red text and
whatever uh but wait I'd rather just
wait to see if the movie is actually
yeah actually your problems
uh yeah I think it's all just a big
cycle at the moment where
journalists and news outlets they know
what's going to get the attention on
their
articles
um you know identity politics actors
saying something controversial yeah and
so they'll ask questions that ultimately
lead a certain way and can get a quote
that they can then post and then that
post will be something that people pick
apart and make videos about and it's
just a big cycle of
unfortunately a lot of films at the
moment are just are trapped in this
bubble where that all they talk about is
identity politics and things that are
gonna annoy certain people and it's
gonna drive rage clicks and get a
negative discussion around the film and
Disney especially have so many people
that don't want them to succeed and that
was where they messed up so badly in the
strike that was because let's be honest
yeah Disney don't like the right wing at
all they've made that abundantly clear
lots of times they don't like the right
wing so what they're relying on is the
left supporting them now when Bob Iger
comes out and he's talking about you
know the unions and stuff like that and
how much they suck and I I could see
that the left just turned on Disney as
well
um and now it's kind of like
yeah it's a very it's very strange and
it's this weird pre-marketing thing
before the marketing even starts where
they just lean so heavily into
um identity politics and I think in
general just capitalism as a whole is
built around
basically what capitalism wants to do is
they want to sell you a product that you
feel is personal to you and that's why
so many of these big Brands they'll
attach their their stuff to Pride
um social movements and so on and it
there will be people there obviously who
who care about these things and want it
but there's also that side of it that's
like well if you support Pride then that
there's going to be a lot a lot of
people that have have this feeling of
being proud and they'll associate your
brand with their personal feelings so
it's almost giving you the attachment of
of a personal feeling towards this brand
that you really gravitate towards it you
want to support them with everything you
can and obviously they play into that
um
and you will see sometimes when they get
backlash like Bud Light have
they got so much backlash and they
completely reversed it and it's like
well you obviously didn't care too much
about that issue in the first place if
you were if you were just gonna be like
oh crap we've lost some money yeah we'll
stop doing it yeah um and I think they
have kind of started to think oh the
best way to sell products is to get
people to become personally attached to
us through their own things that they
really care about like their politics
and their social issues but because of
that you are gonna run into people who
think the opposite and it's gonna
they're gonna be out guns blazing for
you
um and that's kind of that's you know we
we stay away from politics a lot of the
time because it's
ah it's difficult to have a discussion
about things
um on the internet in a a nuanced way
when there's so much people who are
so I think you know you can talk about
people privately or DM someone or even
you know tweet a couple of people but I
think once you're doing on a grand scale
and the the companies are are more
likely going to per foot wrong and
they're going to put a foot right and
yeah it's uh it's very strange that
unless this it's kind of LED towards its
marketing it's got its pros and cons
obviously you know sometimes it works
out sometimes it doesn't but I think
with the subjects of like politics and
everything we talk about there's always
the opposite side where we can hear what
the opposing thing is going to be of
what we say it feels like we have to
just constantly clarify and constantly
bring up this thing and constantly bring
up this thing because it's so easy for
anything we say to then have this
reaction to it when we're aware of what
that reaction will be and it's like
we're no we we know that we we do if we
don't say it and then it just becomes
this
like overly verbose type of discussion
and then you still don't end up saying
enough you still and then if you do
acknowledge it it doesn't even get
acknowledgmented you acknowledged it you
know and and then even going off of what
you're saying with capitalism and the
way how these Studios and these
companies work
the part of it is it just seems so
insincere a lot of the time it seems
like they're pandering to the left side
if we're going to put it in this sort of
black and white discussion well I'm
going to it is that
that's the dichotomy of the Bob Iger
situation is Disney placates and panders
to the Socialist views of the social
views of the left and then he does the
most you know abundantly uh type of
stereotypical right-wing capitalist type
of mentality when discussing how to
treat the workers and he's the leader
he's the head of Disney and I'm not
saying everyone on the right is like
this that's here we go with the fusing
Bobs and trying to acknowledge the
opposite stuff I'm not saying everyone
on the right is like this where's
everyone on the left a certain way
either but in terms of the generality of
the situation that's the big part of it
where it's it does shine an exposure of
you know you hire these writers you get
these actors everyone most of them are
mainly like left-leaning and they're
types of liberal viewpoints right so
that makes sense Hollywood in general
yeah Hollywood in general which used to
be very Republican and very right-wing
now you've got the heads of them though
who
posture themselves with this type of
liberal way of thinking but you see how
they take advantage of everyone else and
The Working Man so now you have this
very clear divided at the end of the day
the heads the leaders they're the pure
capitalists who are taking advantage of
everyone and then when they do these
products what they they do come across
like they're just doing it to placate or
to Pander so an audience can pick up on
enough when something is inauthentic
and then once in a while though it's not
inauthentic and it is just right casting
it is just right decision making it is
just good writing sometimes it is
genuinely good because the artists
themselves allowed their voices to truly
shine
at the same time we can tell though when
the Bud Light example you gave was a
great one of they were just trying to
Pander when this is not what they really
feel you know look I'm I'm not 100 sure
on what's hap what happened with that
but I'm sure that Dylan or whatever
um I don't know her last name she put
out a statement saying that they just
never contacted her again after the
backlash and stuff like that uh so yeah
I mean
it's good that companies are at least
you know supporting these stuff but then
in the back of my mind I'm always
thinking they're doing this for money
because they at the end of the day they
see that there's profit in this somehow
because
they must you know they they
again just back to the whole idea of
they want you to attach your actual
personal identity to their brand so it's
not just a brand to you it's part of
your identity and they do that by
aligning themselves with your beliefs
and your
what you think the world should be like
um and yeah I think it's just kind of
hit a point where it's it's part of the
marketing now and then obviously with
them being left leaning you're instantly
going to get the the backlash
um from people who say well this is you
know they call it out and
it's just a weird thing how that this is
a snow white kids movie and it's uh it's
devolved into what it has where even now
we can't talk about without talking
about politics and kind of tiptoeing
around it and but I've always just been
taught
instead of arguing with someone listen
and just try and talk to them about it
because I truly believe that if you have
a conversation with someone
you're much more likely to change their
mind than just shouting down at them and
saying No this is what you are and
Snow White in the face is really bad in
your a piece of crap for liking it and
we made it better so yeah I I feel like
that that whole situation could have
been handled better and unfortunately
you know the way that outrage media
works on the Internet is
we're probably going to hear a lot more
about Rachel zegler in in
this way for a long time where you're
just seeing lots of videos made about
her because she's now become a source of
income for
people to complain about and well I know
you can probably even accuse us of doing
it and but it's just because it was a
big topic this week and we hope at least
that we've handled it with some Grace
and decorum and talked about it in a way
that you might agree with you might not
agree with but we're more than happy to
hear your opinion so leave it in the
comments below is there any more topics
left or the Marvel's director
we got the girls like how is
it's got to get way worse
yeah female director of
honestly does it start with female
directors
yeah Jeff gonna say just start with
direct when it comes to Marvel doesn't
it honestly it doesn't even matter this
could have been a male director it'd
still be terrible
um yeah uh she says oh god
um
this just circles so that the video that
we did about
um secret Invasion and the Damage brand
and one thing we were bringing up was
how Marvel and their directors don't
seem like they're in tune with the other
projects
you've not been aware of what's going on
with Marvel outside of secret invasion
said I think superhero fatigue
absolutely exists the biggest difference
from the other MCU movies to date is
that the more it's meaning the marbles
is really wacky and silly the worlds we
go into this movie are worlds unlike
others you've seen in the MCU bright
worlds that you haven't seen before uh
The Avengers movies or these epic
conclusions to Chapters of Storytelling
where this uh this is not her quote yeah
never mind ignore that last bit of part
that's the main thing that people are
talking about with what director of the
Marvels has said and this is obviously
coming posts things like
quantumania She-Hulk and I don't know
this is coming out a little bit after
secret Invasion which was the most
serious they were trying to be uh but
I don't think I mean what's your take on
it man because to me I I I just
immediately went well this isn't
this could be fun let's not forget
Everyone likes to talk about Taiko
watiti with Thor love and thunder and
how awful that was
but he Thor Ragnarok everyone loved that
movie and that was wacky and silly and
bright and colorful and I know that when
I go online apparently Avengers 2012 is
now a bad movie or something but that
movie's a blast and it's really funny
it's a really funny movie Marvel has
done the wacky and silly very well the
problem is
there's been a lot of wacky and silly
that hasn't really been Landing all that
well and not that I expected this movie
to be very serious
it just sounds like
well these are the things that people
have been complaining about with Marvels
it doesn't sound like there's an
awareness to this situation
the problem is right it's the words
wacky and silly before
because before you tour when you're
talking I'm thinking about what I'm
gonna say and my words in my head were
they should have just instead of saying
wacky and silly they should have just
said fun that's all they had to say and
it would have totally changed the
conversation and but unfortunately they
went down the two words that no one
really wants to hear in regards to
Marvel at the moment which is wacky and
silly
um I think deep down everyone does kind
of want Marvel to start taking itself
more seriously again you know Iron Man
had jokes he was funny but there was a
serious side to him Captain America his
whole personality was being serious and
doing the right thing Bucky so on and so
forth you know what I mean these
characters that people are like
enamored with Thanos for example
um I I feel that's what people want from
the MCU not crazy over the top being
whacking silly busting jokes all the
time and just derailing the entire film
to tell some five minute joke and yeah
just hearing this it was kind of like
you guys have learned nothing from all
the all the criticism and backlash that
you've had like the last year
like even Spider-Man no way home you
know it has jokes in it it's got those
funny moments but it's kind of it takes
those serious things seriously obviously
we can't we haven't seen the movie but
it's 93 as well yeah
yeah this is how it's being sold
um as being wacky and silly and
I just don't yeah I don't know if I'm
that interested in another whacking
silly Marvel movie obviously you know I
thought the marvelous trailer
it uh yeah look looks fun and I think
they should have just said it it's fun
instead of that I think people are
getting to people are probably getting
you know too hung up on the words
whacking silly and again you're kind of
going back to your prior point where
when it's written down and you're
reading it you kind of put your own spin
on how you feel it was said like you
could easily take our quotes from this
podcast write them down and we're gonna
sound like terrible people which fair
enough yeah you've sussed us out but I
challenge when it's written down it's a
lot it's a lot different
um but yeah I just uh and it if they
were coming out saying this and all the
the last Marvel movies had been a big
success and they'd nailed love and
thunder they'd nailed quantumania with
its tone they're saying this would be
absolutely fine you know people wouldn't
care it's just the fact that there's
been those Duds and misfires that
hearing the words wacky and silly now
are kind of
sort of red flags instead of being
something that we're looking forward to
at least from my point of view anyway I
think most of us want want that balance
you know uh I know that you're not as
much on like I love Guardian three I
know you're not as in love with it as
myself per se
but I think what we I think what we
ultimately craving is we just want
we just want a distinct voices and I
think that's what was the the biggest
refreshing thing like Taiko YTD would
Ragnarok to love and thunder is such a
shining light on the whole thing to me
because people loved Ragnarok and
waititi's voice sounded so authentic to
that experience and it had a vision to
it you know whereas love and thunder was
more of like Marvel just being like
overly wacky and silly and lost a lot of
that visual experience as well and it's
from the same director you could even
kind of apply that with Joss Whedon from
Avengers to Age of Ultron uh and to a
certain extent you know when these
directors return
I I feel like Age of Ultron is actually
a step up in seriousness of uh the first
film yeah um but I don't know if it's
kind of they they do this first movie
and you know it perhaps under the guise
of Kevin feige and they do a good job
and then he thinks all right I'll give
them more free reign on the next one and
that's kind of why
the love and thunder feels like Taiko or
TT turned up to 11. hmm could be man but
we'll see I mean I I feel like it could
still be very
I guess the thing is the way this is
being pitched especially from the
director's words here is it sounds like
a frivolous chapter in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe when you put it in
this in this tone you know what I mean
where we're all waiting for some we
wanted to go back to this is a must-view
experience as a as opposed to another uh
here we go another chapter in here that
is maybe not as important to view right
now when you're just saying that but it
could be it could be she could just be
underselling it who knows
who knows and it's weird to get near the
Costa to do it who's not known for wacky
and silly films to then bring her over
for this it's it's strange it sounds
like more other Marvel committee choice
of hey you've done some smaller films
come over here so we can control you a
little bit yeah and I actually really
like the the Candyman
soft reboot sort of yeah recall we'll
call it
um yeah I'll probably get slated for it
but I I thought that was good uh and but
yeah it wasn't wacky or silly I would
say no so yeah it is kind of weird and
you know what who's gonna get the blame
ultimately I don't feel like near the
Costa will I think it'll be more oh it's
another Marvel thing like Marvel of
forcing them to do this yeah so
again these quotes can be taken out of
context or
you know you focus on just two words out
of an entire article
so yeah we'll we'll see obviously you
know I think the Marvels is the next big
superhero movie isn't it obviously we've
got Loki
um Invincible I'm very excited about gen
V I'm very excited about and then yeah
Loki and the marbles so uh well we'll
see I can't wait to do my review of the
Marvels and then my opening sentence is
going to be guys the biggest difference
from this empty movie from the others is
that this one's wacky and silly the
bright world that you go to here are so
colorful I just want to quote her the
entire time
yeah I think yeah I mean would you even
say that going off the trailer I it
didn't really strike really like pop you
know like nothing about it felt we say
bright worlds I imagine something that
feels
Lush illustrious in some way you know
but there was nothing there that quite
popped definitely look wacky I don't
know yeah maybe we're too hung up on it
I'm just I mean we're still it's you and
I we're still gonna see it the second it
comes out we're still gonna be there and
we're still gonna be here to talk about
it with an open mind yeah and it is just
kind of how the entire conversation
around things gets derailed like I would
have been very happy with those two
trailers not hear anything else until
the movie releases and instead what
happens is you know
the media forwards these questions that
they know are going to get outrage
clicks and people
getting angry and making whole podcasts
about so yeah we'll see how it goes
um I'm sure if the movie's good we'll
forget about these quotes straight away
uh if it's good we'll probably have to
deal with another 200 000 freelancing
videos or um and then Rachel zegler on
top of it and we were gonna have both
Rachel zegler and Brie Larson a
thumbnail for this video we're still
deciding but we just thought
oh
I'll say I'm kind of just hitting a
point where I might just start making
thumbnails I just say it's another
[__] week of the same [__] again
more outrage everyone's on strike
everyone hates our life
we're just fighting and arguing all the
time
I want to come watch my breakdown of
Star Wars A New Hope from 1977. I want
us to grow old and withered here on
camera in real time just big beard yeah
gray and fat friends
not just a tear here as we keep talking
about these news
same thing but I think yeah I think it's
we are kind of getting into a cycle now
where it's becoming very repetitive and
I think there's going to be a
breakthrough and something else is gonna
you know they're saying that the the
comic book movie
era is over and you know there might be
something else that comes in and
supersed it away and replaces it with
something else that becomes a cycle
after a while because Marvel managed to
stay out of controversy for so long as
well I used to see it with Star Wars
where there'd be like constant arguments
about Star Wars all the time and there
wasn't really that with Marvel and
unfortunately they've kind of hit that
point now where they're getting pulled
into it too well I think uh with with
Barbie and what Mario has shown us is
I don't exactly know what category that
would be because the same video game
movie adaptation is a little too broad
and and there's something to be with the
toy adaptations I suppose
but there's some cat there's some Camp
there I think with yeah they're the two
movies they're the only ones that made
over a billion dollars this year right
am I wrong about that I think they're
the only two that I made over a billion
yeah Bobby and uh Mario yeah yeah I
think those are the ones that uh I think
that's gonna influence a lot of the
direction now of what people focus on to
be the next Boom the Nintendo Cinematic
Universe
and the Mattel Cinematic Universe is it
Mattel I mean is
yeah there's a lot of video games that
haven't been adapted into movies and
that might be the the next way that
things go and they seem to have actually
cracked it where they can make so many
decent ones I always like Silent Hill
but for guilty pleasure but yeah that's
a good movie that's uh that's the that's
the episode no doubt we'll have people
telling us we'd probably say one thing
like and then 10 minutes say the exact
opposite and just cause [__] for
ourselves but yeah thanks for watching
with us again guys uh we really
appreciate it
honestly seeing the numbers grow on this
thing it's absolutely incredible and uh
we're so glad you guys keep coming back
every week too thank you listen to us
Mumble on about stuff if you want to
listen to us on the go we're on Spotify
Apple podcasts Amazon podcasts wherever
you get your podcasts we're probably
there making rubbish rubbish content and
yeah thanks a lot so much guys for for
sticking with us you know it's been a
bit of a weird week because it's not
been that major release to talk about so
it's been kind of scattered but we will
be back next week to talk more about
Blue Beetle
um are you going to see it again Greg no
I didn't like it okay
okay I liked it
but let's hope it fails so we can have a
thumbnail if it fails then we got a good
thumbnail yeah big red text
oh DC the end something it's KC failure
oh Kathleen Kennedy
yeah cutting Kennedy in there for some
reason
um so yeah thanks for coming back again
guys we love you and uh we'll see you
next time mate thank you